[Music]
i have with me david pakman
he is a progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pakman
he is a beta male 1
[Music]
david pacman he is a beta male 1
david pacman he is
patman he is a pain
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a baby male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse will we we gotta
that's a lot that's a lot hang on with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david pacman he is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
gave it pacman he is a baby
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming on i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like
and you're wasting my time i appreciate
that all right thank you
for coming goodbye goodbye
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we are
standing by for joe biden who is going
to be
addressing the nation in advance of the
end of the year holiday we have
christmas coming up
hanukkah is over new year's etc etc
uh joe biden received his first dose of
the vaccine yesterday dr anthony fauci
was vaccinated today i'll have video of
that for you momentarily
and at this point i know he's just
president-elect but isn't he really the
only president we have and what i mean
is
trump's missing uh trump nothing on his
schedule today nothing yesterday
nothing the day before nothing the day
before
he met with his secretary of defense
privately the day before
he signed something privately the day
before he had a private cabinet meeting
the day before
nothing lunch with pence etc i
we trump's not even really the president
at this point in time uh trump's gone
uh although he did call into that
completely wacky
uh toilet paper uh turning point usa
event that we watched some of
last night so maybe we will get to a
little bit
of that momentarily
but yes we will be hearing from joe
biden
in a little bit and i expect that he
will comment
on the pandemic i expect he will comment
on receiving the vaccine and we're going
to get a bunch of other things now
if you've been paying attention to
donald trump's tweets
he's back to tweeting about massive
dumps
um the democrats dumped hundreds of
thousands of
ballots in the swing states late in the
evening it was a rigged election
still going this stuff and as you can
see
i'm right there a huge massive dumps and
someone adding the low-flow toilets made
the situation even worse
absolutely um i believe this tweet
tells us a lot about why donald trump is
finding himself having to flush
uh 10 to 10 to 15 times so donald trump
is tweeting he absolutely is tweeting
um let's make sure we have audio up here
just so we don't miss when things get
going i did want to go over a couple of
things with you
here is mike pence speaking at the
turning point usa event just moments ago
he's talking like trump could still get
another term take a look
[Applause]
and as our election contest continues
continues
i'll make you a promise we're going to
keep fighting until
every legal vote is counted that's
happened we've got the votes
we're going to keep fighting until every
illegal vote is thrown out
that's happened
we're gonna win georgia we're gonna save
america
no you're not dude biden won georgia
and we'll never stop fighting to make
america great again okay so there's that
um super chat there's no super okay i
see someone's trolling me someone's
trying to make me sad that there aren't
any super chats i will answer
people are like why aren't you reading
the super chats because there are none
okay i get it there's no super chats yet
but we'll get to those
they also are introducing charlie kirk
who's like the putative head of this
organization
with a completely insane hype just look
at this
i run the largest pro-american student
organization in the country
fighting for the future of our republic
we will be a country
that has its best check this out we will
build a future where america remains the
greatest country
ever to exist in the history of the
world all of that
[Music]
[Music]
the best part is him walking out looking
very confused
like wait what the hell he seems as
shocked but
he seems as shocked by the hype uh as as
we are interestingly enough so that's
pretty funny
um and then one other thing was
the anthony fauci vaccination video
thank you for coming today
any last minute questions concerns no
all right alpha fouchy
trying to get a good intramuscular
injection here
thanks for helping intramuscular
giga chad fauci strongly vaccinated
trump missing
[Applause]
there it is all right dr fauci uh very
very strongly vaccinated there
and it's all it is absolutely all
happening
okay a few super chats rando gee says
here a super chat
david abel says here another super chat
jd numero ocho says hey or david have a
super chat for your troubles all right
thank you guys i appreciate that
um let's see here
sam cedar accused you of using dominion
to steal subscribers from him on a show
today hey can people get me these clips
so i guess yesterday
sam had some kind of alpha male
compilation a mashup
that was a parody of my beta male
compilation can someone please send me
that and can someone also please send me
the sam cedar dominion claims about
subs i think it would be funny for me to
do like a reaction video people
we gained our the most subscribers back
in uh you know september when we got to
a million october
uh when we were playing up this fake war
with sam so i think that could generate
some good ancillary content if people
can get me those clips i would
appreciate it
um okay what else did i have
oh thank you to jrdubs
cheeky quest the proper talent sir
gavin usgar
that is um five people who grabbed
twitch prime subs
which puts us at okay zero plus five i
can do this
zero plus five is five no zeros to carry
it's five very good we got that um
and i i certainly will open the phone
lines like i did yesterday if we get to
a hundred members and twitch subs just a
reminder
we are not stopping the count i know
there's people who want me to
continue the count and there's people
who want me to stop the count on new
members
we will continue we will count all
memberships
um and yes the coupon code fresh start
does work
although we suspect a joe biden's
attorney general is going to put a stop
to the discounts
uh peggy says you make my day david
thanks peggy
reuben says toss a coin to your pacman
oh valley of plenty
nicole says became a proud member a week
and a half ago thank you so much for
covering live announcements addresses
etc appreciate that
sam and war and a few people
participating
not to start something but did you
notice she didn't use gloves on the
first patient
says monique i didn't notice that i
didn't see that
we'll have to review that maybe uh maybe
after
we also are standing by this is video of
um i guess governor greg abbott of texas
is getting the
the vaccine it's all kind of crazy
because this is the guy who said that
there's nothing to see here so we'll
keep an eye on that and maybe get back
to it depending on what happens
from the standpoint of timing with joe
biden all right i have something
really special for you guys today okay
but i want to make it
so i have for you know sometimes we play
these different voicemails from our
regular callers they call in as
characters
they call in with fake names they call
me 20 times we all have a grand old time
okay i have a voicemail today
it's not from a character it's not from
a regular caller
this is one voicemail from one person
giving what she believes is an accurate
view of the world
and i believe she may espouse 10
conspiracy theories
during this short voicemail that's only
90 seconds okay
i i would i'm saving this for the show
for today's podcast but i would be
willing to do a david pakman show
world exclusive premiere during this
live stream
if you guys are willing to help me count
the conspiracy theories that are in this
one
voicemail can i get your commitment
and maybe if you think that this is
really the craziest conspiracy voicemail
you've ever heard
maybe you'll grab a subscription at
jointpacman.com okay but i won't i won't
hold you to that
okay and as you can see dennis here says
how have i not been arrested yet my
discounts are
too criminal that's true that's
absolutely true
there's no uh there's no question about
that whatsoever all right let's take a
listen
here's the challenge count the
conspiracy theories
in this voicemail here we go hi david
i'm a nurse myself i live in florida
and my name is vivian and i'd like to
say that you
are a fool sorry conspiracies or lies so
like saying i'm a fool
if you don't believe i'm a fool that
would count as a lie if you do believe
i'm a fool then she's telling the truth
okay
i think i'm not a fool so i'm an account
that is a lie the elections were fraud
trump won by a landslide three
was all a confiscation to
steal the election four uh from trump
biden is a crook five he is corrupt
about our country okay so
i am 100 percent agree with trump
i think that interview with kill me was
excellent
and people like you and cnn and msnbc
and nbc and all your stations that
basically report the lie 11. okay
and they shouldn't even be called
reporters 12.
because you're all in the pockets of
soros bill gates 13. people like him
discussing what you're doing to this
country
and uh that listen to you that believe
you
it's really a darn shame 16.
you should be ashamed of yourself for
calling yourself an american
17 people like you shouldn't even live
in this country 18.
don't change our country you've done
enough harm with your
stupid ass 19
oh my god holy
[ __ ] yeah okay people are saying i
should be ashamed
that's probably true some of the things
that have happened on this program are
shameful
but that that's not why she said i
should be ashamed so i do think that
number 17 does count
i have 19 lies or conspiracies in that
93 second voicemail i think that's a
record
i think that's a wreck i don't think
i've ever seen anything like that
you know my first listen i saw only
nine lies or conspiracies
but and people are saying she didn't
mention the jews
she mentioned george soros which is
essentially mentioning the jews that's
it's a catch-all
now would you say george you know you
betcha okay
uh odwdinc
was so impressed by that that they have
gifted 19
subscriptions on twitch because there
were 19 lies
i love that i absolutely love that
that's that's fantastic
uh thank you very much i appreciate that
um that is abs that is certainly a
record i've never seen
anything like that it's it's it's truly
stunning uh 19 lies and conspiracies in
93 seconds that's what 93 divided by 19
that's roughly a lie every four seconds
that's insane imagine if i gave her a
five minute
a five minute platform she would
probably be able to get uh
hundreds hundreds those are trump-like
numbers yeah absolutely
uh okay very good so that's the most
insane voicemail we've probably ever
received
uh do i prefer people sign up on twitch
or my website okay here listen here's
the deal
i've said this before i love it when you
sign up anywhere
anywhere you sign up i love if i'm
completely honest
we get the most when you sign up on our
website when you do these website sign
ups i'll even show you what it looks
like this is joinedpakman.com
we keep all but two percent of every
dollar and if i put in the coupon code
fresh start you'll see what happens my
six dollar a month subscription
oh actually i'm connected to this in a
way that the coupon codes won't display
in any case um if i use the code fresh
start
six dollars becomes only a dollar eighty
this is the best place to sign up
okay but we will take bezos bucks for
sure
we will take we will take it all you
know we'll just wrap it all
any any large massive dumps of
memberships of any kind we accept
that's the point okay very good all
right but let me get the numbers updated
1276 so that's 27
plus 5 is 32 okay
check my math a few other super chats
peter says thanks
for being a voice based in reality and
truth in this insane world enjoy your
show
laura says how much would people pay for
her phone number to set her straight
yeah i'm not interested in doxing people
i do have that woman's phone number
but i would never even joke about doing
that
michigan mama says one misuse of a word
confiscation to steal the election
yeah oh it was that's not the only one
sizzix sap says hello from netherlands
can't wait until they throw out purdue
and lefleur from the senate and convict
the trump
family and half of the gop your
expectations may be a little bit
aggressive
i don't know i don't know about that
melanie says do you think trump is going
to continue to submit lawsuits and hold
rallies after january 20th
lawsuits no rallies maybe
trump should pardon pakman for illegal
discounts yeah i have my legal team
trying to get a pardon from from trump
in fact that's actually that's actually
happening
mzf says how will democracy work when
the electorate consists less of informed
voters
i learned about in school and more of
fans of political
influencers it's a really it's a big
problem and in fact check out i did
i did a segment yesterday on the stream
and did a longer segment on today's
broadcast show about uh the sort of
misunderstanding
about what education and empiricism and
science are
abraham friedman says what happened to
tim poole
is he this desperate for attention i'll
agree glenn greenwald in your view
what happened to tim i don't know what
happened to tim um
yeah i don't know i mean i think i've
mentioned before that i
i'm no longer in touch with tim we used
to have sort of like a like a
oh hold on a second we knew we talked
privately but then he he sort of like
went public with our private
conversations and i told him that
when we talk privately i don't think i'm
talking to a reporter that you know it's
it's i'm not the i consider these
private and he said he doesn't
believe in the hillary clinton
difference between being a
public and private person and i was like
tim no that's not what i'm saying
i'm not saying i'm a different person
privately and publicly what i'm saying
is if i have like a private if i if i'm
texting with you
i don't imagine that then you publicize
the content of those texts
and he just disagreed so i haven't
spoken to him since and he recently
actually
did try to send me some information
about
so-called voter fraud and um
i just didn't write back because again i
just you know
i i don't have confidence that we're
communicating privately
and it's just all kind of weird so
that's the back story with tim but
otherwise i don't know what's been going
on
i don't know what's been going on with
tim you tell me do you think cannabis
legalization is more of a possibility
with the incoming administration much
love
of decriminalization at the federal
level
and i believe there will be more
legalization at the state level
that's uh that's that's my sense of it
okay
let me thank some new members kyle
mizrahi
love it number 33
derek smith number 34 andrew stilson
number 35
nina young is number 36 steven phillips
37
oh i don't know i'm gonna have trouble
with this is it jeez veersma
number 38 i apologize if i butchered
that
tracy smith number 39 and zachary miller
is new member number 4040
at joinpackman.com
also thanks via twitch to dranoa now
here for
11 months wc
and um who else carly knight
pushing us all the way to 43. if you're
just joining us we're standing by for
joe biden with a reportedly major
announcement from delaware
after getting his first vaccine dose in
advance of the
uh holiday super spreader events
we are starting to see now remember my
prediction was
and again this is based on experts not
just me coming up with it
i believe we will see a case peak in
early january
and that then with the weather starting
to warm in some places
and with the vaccine going out cases
will start to decline
permanently i believe that deaths will
peak
a few weeks after that we are starting
to see a bit of a rounding here
in terms of cases but that may be
because of the weekend
we're going to continue following it but
we need to be very very careful
with what's going on at the end of the
year i'm guessing we're going to hear
from joe biden a little bit about that
and meanwhile donald trump's still
completely missing publicly but is again
tweeting about huge massive dumps the
democrats dumped hundreds of thousands
of ballots in the swing states late in
the evening
it was a rigged election and maybe just
for kicks
we'll do one dumps song
just just to get it on the record i
think it is good anytime that that comes
up
the biggest dumps they call them dumps
big massive dumps
[Music]
big massive dumpster
okay anyway i think that's enough of
that
but um okay very good let's let's
continue
uh angel says he wants to be new member
number 69.
rusty wants to know if fresh start is a
beta male
hygiene product uh
no how insane is it that trump
administration has yet to address the
cyber attack well trump tweeted it was
china
i mean it wasn't but that is uh that's
that's something
um oh uh here's by the way i wanted to
run this by you
i got a few emails from people saying
that some youtubers were recently
analyzing my old interview
that i did with white nationalist
richard spencer
and um folks had the idea of me
kind of like reviewing that interview
because it's been so many years now
just to see what my thoughts are about
it i don't know if that would be
interesting for a live stream to be
perfectly frank like i'm willing to do
it but i don't know that people want to
sit through that
all right some people like it some
people don't like the idea
okay something to look into matthias
says hey david don't you think it's very
likely
that folks like maria bartoromo are paid
a lot of money by trump for putting this
weird stuff out
no i don't think maria bartoromo is a
trump sycophant because he pays her
i think she's well paid by fox and she
likes
access to trump she likes having a
relationship with trump and that's why
she's doing it
i don't think i don't think i don't
think trump is paying her
do i think covet 19 is actually a
stomach virus with all of these massive
dumps across the country
that's a question for a
gastroenterologist
um yeah shannon
says i enjoy your interviews and would
enjoy more uh more some post-interview
thoughts
what did you think about your discussion
with douglas murray
i thought it was wholly unproductive to
be perfectly honest
i wish uh i wish i had a different
different view samuel says david what's
with these
big massive dumps of memberships one
second it's two the next it's 32 where
are they coming from nobody knows
it's a fair question it's a very fair
question um
i mean just now we've got uh
oh hold on a second we might we might
actually hit the goal
let's look here let's take a look brock
willard is number 44.
john thames is number 45. kelly rogers
is number 46.
cindy thomas is number 47. ashley yb
is number 48. michelle dubois 49.
amber smith is number 50. holly hess
is number 51 but there's more
b rogen camp is number 52
joel dippert is number 53
and jerome lewis is number 54. nicely
done
very nicely done jesus christ
says via twitch david you need to start
talking about economics in a more
substantive name
a name what we need everyone to
understand the ideological differences
between conservatives classical
economists
and neo-liberals leftists
keynesians yes listen i i we do a lot of
economics on the show
and uh you know i will i will regularly
explain
concepts like what is the difference
between fiscal and monetary policy
what are diminishing marginal returns
how do these yeah
i do what i can i do what i can
um i guess you mean in a more
substantive way
beezus okay very good
um got it got it
let's see what else did i have here oh
do we want to see what's going on with
uh
oh well i don't know what this is i
guess uh i guess greg abbott got his
vaccine
and that's it so we're just standing by
now
for joe biden and we'll make sure that
we are
in hd for everybody always want to be in
hd
uh very good thank you monique says do
you have plans to do another show with
jesse lee peterson it's always
fascinating to watch you keep your cool
white
while talking to him yeah i i was
supposed to be on his show
um it's just all the same now you know i
it's like how many times am i going to
do it
i don't know will i live stream when i
get the vaccine well
i'm probably going to get the vaccine
at a cvs or walgreens
and um i don't know that they would
appreciate live streaming in there plus
i guess i'd have to like mute when i'm
giving my personal information i don't
know that's complicated
i think i'd be more likely to to film it
and then later
just put up a clip people asking
if i've heard from stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell
ii about going to atlanta this weekend i
did
so um stephen kenneth destiny bonnell ii
has been canvassing in georgia
for uh raphael warnock and john ossoff
he very graciously invited me to
participate
um this weekend and or next week no not
this weekend next he invited me to
participate next weekend
i think it's great what he's doing i
graciously declined i'm not traveling
right now i'm not getting on a plane
right now
but i did tell him that i would gladly
coordinate with him to stream
while they are doing stuff let me see
okay i said
um so steven asked me about going i said
i'm not interested i'm interested but
i'm not flying anywhere right now
plus i'm going to be away that weekend
but i would do a stream covering what
you're doing
if you will have someone filming you and
they can get me a video feed i will
simply stream showing what you're doing
encouraging people to phone bank etc
um so uh
yeah we i would love to do that and i've
told stephen and we're going to try to
coordinate that
i think i think he's interested in doing
that but i'm not i'm not getting on a
plane right now and i've i've things
going on over the new year
um yeah safe things very very safe
things going on
okay jf gambi says i'm glad
it's on soros these days it gives us
freemasons a vacation and by the way
stop disclosing your secret secret plots
on youtube it's not fair
thanks okay thank you
do you think trump will end up saying
the republican party conspired with
biden to steal the election
he'll say some republicans and he's
already including georgia governor brian
kemp
in that list all right
stefan says is the cyber attack only one
coming in from china and will soon be
down to zero
exactly yeah can dump song be downloaded
somewhere
yeah if so the um okay we'll get to that
after because we've got joe biden here
let's take a listen
good afternoon everyone strongly masked
before i take questions i'd like to
questions merry christmas and happy
holidays
this has been a uh one of the toughest
years we've ever faced as a nation
and the pandemic the economic crisis
calls for
racial justice historic and punishing
wildfires and storms so this season of
reflection carries a much deeper meaning
than it usually does
over 320 000 lives
lost to this virus and jill and i
send our prayers as i'm sure all of you
do to all who are facing this dark
winter
with an empty seat at the dinner table
where a loved one used to sit and talk
shocking he said merry christmas trump
said christmas would never that way
would never be said if biden won
times through no fault of your own i
might add
unable to sleep at night weigh down with
the worry of what tomorrow will bring
for you
and for your family we're especially
grateful
for the health care workers on the front
lines the scientists
the researchers the clinical trial
participants on the front lines of the
vaccine
who deserve our thanks and who delivered
us
scientific breakthrough and for all of
you who
have deployed family deployed family
members in the military
we know what it's like we know what that
experience is like how difficult it can
be
especially at this time of the year
our family knows your sacrifice and our
hearts are always with you
but keep the faith throughout this year
we had to forego many of our favorite
holiday traditions
we have as families as communities and
as a country
for the bidens we usually have 20 to 25
family members over for christmas dinner
and then the immediate family 14 of our
kids and grandkids and
their spouses uh for uh coming down the
stairs on christmas morning but not this
year
like we did over thanksgiving we all
have to care enough for each other that
we
have to stay apart just a little bit
longer
i know it's hard we have a long way to
go
but we're grateful that we've got the
vaccine
and yesterday in an effort to instill
some confidence in the vaccine
i had my shot administered in public and
i got a chance to thank all those nurses
and docs
at christiana hospital for what they've
been putting up with and doing for so
long
i look forward to the second shot and i
have absolute confidence in the vaccine
but we're in short supply taking the
vaccine
from a vial into the arm of millions of
americans
is one of the biggest operational
challenges
the united states has ever faced for 300
million people
and we're going to take many more months
for that to happen
in the meantime this pandemic rages on
experts experts say things are going to
get worse before they get better
not withstanding the fact we have the
vaccine
as you all know we're averaging a death
rate of close to 3
000 people a day that means we're going
to lose tens of thousands of more lives
in the months to come
and the vaccine won't be able to stop
that
so we'll still have to remain vigilant
we need everyone to mask up
stay socially distanced avoid large
gatherings
particularly inside we need to work in a
bipartisan way
that's the only way we're going to get
through this in tough times
we have our first hint and glimpse of
bipartisanship i applaud the congress
their economic relief package that
included funding for vaccine
distribution
much needed temporary relief for workers
families and small businesses
in this election the american people
made it clear
they want us to reach across the aisle
and work together
on matters of national concern to get
something done
and i believe that to be the case from
the very beginning of my campaign and
i'm happy to see
members of congress heeding that message
as well from their own constituents
leaders in both house and senate both
parties
deserve credit for making the hard
compromises to get this done
but like all compromises it's far from
perfect
but it does provide vital relief at a
critical moment
however as i've said all along
this bill is just the first step
a down payment let's hope and addressing
the crisis the crises more than one that
we're in
there's a lot more work to do
early next year i'm going to put forward
to the congress
my plans for what comes next we'll need
more help
to fully distribute the vaccine we're
going to need more testing
in order to be able to open our schools
we need more funding
to help firefighters and police many of
whom are being laid off as i speak
and the same with nurses risking their
lives on the front lines the same
for millions of hurting families who are
unable to put food on the table
pay rent or the mortgage
unemployment's extended for another 10
weeks it's going to take a lot longer
than that
but congress did its job this week
and i can and i must ask them to do it
again
next year but even with the changes in
approach
i'm going to put in place in late
january
people are still going to be getting
sick and dying from covert
one thing i promise you about my
leadership during this crisis
i'm going to tell it to you straight i'm
gonna tell you the truth shouldn't he be
telling us everything will be fine on
january 21 that's what trump would do
the darkest days
in the battle against covet are ahead of
us not behind us
wow so we need to prepare ourselves to
steal our spines
as frustrating it is to hear it's going
to take
patience persistence and determination
to beat this virus there'll be no time
to waste
and taking the steps we need to turn
this crisis around no malarkey there
my administration will start to do this
its part
on our first day in office with masking
requirements a new strategy for testing
accelerated protection protective gear
and we're going to challenge congress
and the american people
to step up immediately as well
to do their part as of the relief bill
passed by congress is another challenge
which my administration will confront on
a bipartisan basis
a massive cyber security breach
against the u.s companies many of them
as well as federal agencies and there's
still so much we don't know
including the full scope of the breach
or the extent of the damage it has
caused
but we know this much this attack
constitutes a
grave risk to our national security
it was carefully planned and carefully
orchestrated
it was carried out by using
sophisticated cyber tools
the attackers succeeded in catching the
federal government off guard and
unprepared
foreign actors have been working this
breach since last
late last year at least last year
setting the landscape to compromise our
systems
scraping up sensitive information from
our world-class tech
sector and from private businesses
and from united states government
agencies
the truth is this the trump
administration
failed to prioritize cyber security well
yeah
it did that from eliminating or
downgrading cyber coordinators
in both the white house and at the state
department to firing the director of
cyber space and infrastructure security
agency to president trump's irrational
downplaying of the seriousness of this
attack enough's enough
in an age when so much of our lives are
conducted online
cyber attacks must be treated as a
serious threat
by our leadership at the highest levels
we can't let this go unanswered that
means making clear
and publicly who is responsible for the
attack and taking meaningful steps to
hold them in account
initial indications including from
secretary pompeo
secretary of state and attorney general
william barr suggest that russia
russia is responsible for this breach
but trump said it might be chinese
certainly fits russia's long history of
reckless disruptive cyber activities but
the trump administration
needs to make an official attribution
this assault happened on donald trump's
watch
when he wasn't watching oh boy it's
still his responsibility as president
to defend american interest for the next
four weeks
but rest assured that even if he does
not
take it seriously i will
well i'm disappointed by the response of
president trump i was pleased to see
leaders in both parties in the congress
speak out loudly and clearly
on this attack again i want to thank
prominent republicans in the senate
particularly for speaking out it's a
sign
a sign that with a new administration we
can confront these threats
on a bipartisan basis with a united
front
here at home bipartisan i'm not sure
about mitch mcconnell doesn't seem
interested in this
and a warning to our adversaries in the
meantime
the president's team for the next four
weeks need to cooperate
fully which they haven't been doing to
share information that becomes available
on both the impact and our response
good luck with that to ensure a smooth
transition
to protect the american people as
administrations change
over the next month i intend to continue
focusing on building my team
so the right people are in place on day
one of my administration
to take over this effort to prioritize
cyber security across the board
and i'll consult with experts to plan
for the steps that my administration
will take
in order to secure our systems improve
our cyber defenses
and to better withstand future attacks
that we know will come
and to impose cost on those who conduct
them
and i fully expect bipartisan support
from this based on what we've heard so
far
our adversaries are highly capable cyber
threats are among the greatest threats
to our global security
in the 21st century i believe we have to
treat them with the same seriousness of
purpose
that we treated threats of other
unconventional weapons
if the work of their allies to establish
clear
international rules and mechanisms would
force them
and consequences for those countries
that violate them i want to close with
this
as i look at the first of what will be
millions of vaccinations
going in the arms of americans after
hundreds
thousands of lives lost
a congress finally passing an economic
relief package after months and months
of delay
at a new urgency for a bipartisan
approach to cyber security after years
of a president
who refused to stand up to our
adversaries and hold them accountable
i'm reminded of a quote this season from
a jesuit priest named alfred delt
he wrote quote advent is a time for
rousing
delp believed that first we are shaken
to our depths
and then we're ready for a season of
hope
as a nation we've certainly been shaken
to our depths this year
now it's time to awaken to get moving
time for hope we've gotten through tough
times before in this nation
we'll get through these difficult times
as well and we'll do it by coming
together
by working with one another by being
you've heard me say many times but we
are at our best
the united states of america there are
certain things that rise way above
partisan differences
that threaten the united states there
are
national security interests that require
us to cooperate
and i'm confident i'm confident we'll be
able to do that
after a year of pain and loss it's time
to unite
to heal to rebuild
for all those who are suffering right
now
who've had enormous loss lie at night
wondering tomorrow's bring i'd say well
god bless you all and i promise you
we're going to continue to push as hard
as we can
to finish the job may god bless you all
may god protect our troops merry
christmas and happy holidays to you all
whoa i'll be happy to take some
questions questions
megan i'll let you tell me who's
thank you mr president-elect president
obama once referred to
this emerging cyber battlefield as the
wild west president trump in commenting
on this most recent breach
said the situation was well under
control given what you just said about
this
that it represents a grave risk do you
believe it also represents an act of war
and will you respond in kind if so
the answer is first of all it is a grave
risk and it continues
i see no evidence that it's under
control
i've seen none heard of none defense
department won't even brief us
on many things so i know of nothing
that suggests it's under control this
president hasn't even identified
who is responsible yet number two
the question of the damage done
remains to be determined we have to look
at very closely
the nature of the breaches how extensive
they are
and what damage has been done and
thirdly
there's going to be a necessity as
president obama and i and our
administration talked about
we need international society
international
rules of the road on cyber security
we have to bring along our allies and
our friends
so we hold everyone accountable who
breaches any of these basic fundamental
rules
and lastly i believe that
when i learn the extent of the damage
and in fact who is formally responsible
they can be assured that we will respond
and probably respond in kind there's
many options which i will not
discuss now why not lay out those kind
of options publicly though
isn't the part not even president why
would russia felt some impunity if it is
indeed russia to do what they've done
here
we have just not the time really for
that done that in any other areas where
we have faced international crises
we don't sit here and say that we're
going to
strike you with a nuclear weapon we
don't sit and we're going to say
and so on let us determine what the
extent of the damage is
and i promise you there will be a
response on another issue sir as you
know the
runoff elections in georgia could well
determine whether
shouldn't biden be kicking the reporter
out for asking follow-ups
in january is the are you waiting for
the outcome of those two races to make
some of the final selections for your
cabinet including
uh the attorney general the most
significant outstanding uh
cabinet secretary you have to pick no
not based on the attorney general it's
just a matter of getting to it through
it
and being able to announce them all
they'll all be announced either just
before the investigation
of your son in discussions with your
team and with potential just happened
there candidates about
no attorney general no i guarantee you
i'm going to do what i said that was
weird the attorney general of the united
states america is not
the president's lawyer i will appoint
someone who i expect to enforce the law
as the law is written not guided by me
thank you sir
thank you mr president-elect there is
growing concern today
about that new variant of uh copen 19
sweeping across
the uk should the united states right
now
impose a travel ban on flights coming in
from the uk
as you know there already is one
unrelated to that finding that new
strain
and the question is whether or not at
the very least
it only allows americans coming home
to be able to come back to the states
citizens
one of the things i'm waiting to get a
response from my
covet team is whether or not we should
require
testing before they get on an aircraft
to fly home number one
and number two when they get home should
they quarantine that's my instinct but
i'm
waiting to hear from my experts right
now you talked about how you want to
propose
a new code relief plan when you do take
office
it took more than six months for
congress to reach this new deal
americans are suffering at this moment
how can you
assure americans that a relief will come
and come soon you all ask the most
interesting questions
have you ever known anyone in the
history of the united states of america
that could be president and assure
exactly what the congress is going to do
i can't assure anything but i can tell
you what i expect fair
i fully expect on those critical issues
that we're facing
number one being able to get all
the work we need done and all the
funding
to be able to get that vaccine in
everyone's arm and that's 300 million
people
we'll get that done because you're going
to see that the responsibility has
already been recognized by the
republicans and democrats in the
congress
because the constituency is going to
demand it
number one number two all those people
are out there hurting
lost jobs for no fault of their own
they've extended unemployment for 10
weeks
simply not sufficient necessary to get
it done to get through the holidays
but i predict you will get cooperation
and get that done
i've been arguing from the very
beginning and told how i love it it
makes me sound so much younger how naive
i am
about how the congress works i think
i've been proven right
wrong across the board the things that
are left to deal with from
employment to people needing
unemployment insurance
to the ability to have access to health
care the ability to get
this they treat treatment for free etc
all of that
is something that the public is not
going to stand for
us not doing and i think with donald
trump
not in the way that will also enhance
the prospect of things getting done
that's true will your plan include a new
round of stimulus checks to the american
people and if so for how much
well look that's a that's a negotiating
issue
but it will yes it will and i think by
the way i think we uh
owe bernie sanders and his republican
colleagues
thanks for getting not all the stimulus
we looked for 1200 but getting 600 done
i think you're seeing that there is a
clear understanding
that these issues go beyond any ideology
people are desperately hurting and the
republicans are hurting as badly as
democrats
there are a few people and i'm not
saying they're responsible for any of
this
a few people are doing extremely well in
that case shape recovery
and and they're doing fine but they
still need
access to the vaccines they still need
access
to making sure that we are able to
handle
crises in the hospitals etc so i think
they're on the things relating to
a vaccine distribution which is going to
cost
billions more dollars it's simply going
to cost
billions more dollars we need national
standards the layout to help governors
disturb
how they're going to get that vaccine
throughout their throughout their
communities number one number two
we're going to need to take care of
those people who through no fault of
their own
are unemployed they've worked like hell
but they have no job because of the
coveted crisis
and thirdly we're going to have to begin
to rebuild the country
we can't wait we can't wait to rebuild
the economy
we're going to have to start doing that
now on infrastructure programs and a
whole range of other things
i think the uh sort of the dawn is
broken on the vast majority of people
there are still people who don't want to
help
there's still people who are insisting
my way or the highway
but the vast majority the members of
congress i believe will be able to work
out those
those uh specific issues that are of
national consequence
thank you mr president thank you
whoa huge glass picked it up with one
hand that's crazy
i'm still not sure if i heard you say
specifically though sir what is your ask
of the congress in just one month's time
what is your ask of the congress after
you've
have watched over these many months and
people in your party as well
did not um necessarily act as quickly
as some americans would have liked what
is your ask i think that's jeff zeleny
we laid out there in detail but it
relates to four things
number one making sure we have all the
money we need
to get the vaccine to 300 million
americans yeah it's a little like i love
the pressing of the
of any president on quest on on details
but it's like he said it will include
money and enhance unemployment
he can't really say how much until he's
in there and he sees the situation and
sees what i mean
if you're like we're going to give
everybody 13.50 like of course he's not
going to say and engage in food
shortages they're not in a position
where they get thrown out of their homes
i would also be asking for a moratorium
on
being evicted from your homes for
failure to pay rent
moratoriums on relating to the issue of
whether or not your mortgage are being
paid
thirdly i think it's critically
important we provide
all of the ppe as well as the direct
payments to small bid businesses and
others to be able to stay open
to be able to keep their people employed
that is something that's going to
increase as time moves
and lastly we're going to need to make
sure that we're in a position
that we can provide for the opportunity
for people to begin to go back to work
and get new jobs developing
infrastructure
given the narrow majorities in the house
and senate you've watched many
administrations come and go do you
believe that you will have a honeymoon
to get things i don't think it's a
honeymoon at all i think it's a
nightmare that everybody's going through
and they all say it's got to end
it's not a honeymoon they're not doing
me a favor
i'll ask you a rhetorical question i
don't expect you to answer
and that is do you think that
republicans who are losing their
businesses do you think republican
constituents out there who
can't pay their mortgage do you think
they're not letting their republican
representatives know they got a problem
do you think the person who just lost
some a family member
and is worried about losing another one
who happens to be a republican a staunch
republican
isn't telling his or her republican
senator or state representative you've
got to help you've got to get something
done
do you think all those people who are
making judgments of whether or not
i'm my child will be able to go to
school and i have to stay home
and i can't go to work therefore i have
no income are all democrats
i think there's been a dawning here and
look
you have a different team in town you
have a different team in town
i'm not going to villainize the
opposition but i'm going to stand and
say this is what we got to do because
they know it it's great that's a
villainized but he shouldn't naively
think mitch mcconnell will work with him
we want to make sure that we are going
to
sign a new trade agreement with a b or c
this is life and death that's why i
believe we'll get it done
sir if i could ask a follow-up to the
attorney general decision
you and president obama selected eric
holder on december 1st
every recent president has selected
their
attorney general by this point what is
taking you so long to make this critical
decision and do you believe that this is
a time
in the post-trump era where you need
someone who
is not steeped in politics these are
fair questions i see people upset
this is called journalism guys first of
all we've done we've gone faster than
everybody in the total cabinet
so we not president obama yourself sir
the whole cabinet
the whole cabinet oh captain well there
were a few missteps on commerce as you
remember but
i do i don't want to raise him though um
but look um uh this is i know nasty
question is joking
but there's other comments that seem to
be serious uh
who will instill the greatest confidence
in the professionals at doj
to know once again that there is no
politics
there's no politics as you know there's
been
a great debate about in every single
appointment
whether or not people there are enough
african-americans enough
uh hispanics enough asian pacific
americans enough
people who have are new and young so
we're just working through it it's not
by design
there's not an obvious choice in my mind
thank you sir thank you merry christmas
merry christmas
hey um you just spoke about
uh your confidence that there will it'll
be possible to get things done once
president trump has left
office um excuse me not just because
he's left office
because it's all becoming obvious
exactly what's at stake
right but but even so are you concerned
about the effects
long term that his presidency and and
now in the transition
his refusal to concede his challenges to
the election
will have on american politics will have
on the republican party
especially if he does take the step of
filing for reelection
next month or running to run in 2024
um you know are you concerned about him
lingering around i know
i see you smiling but a soft basket and
um kind of a corolla
uri to that um would you consider filing
for re-election early next year to show
that you're not going to be a lame duck
oh my god i'm not going to be a lame
duck just watch me
just watch me i've been saying this in
the very beginning
look let's just get the work of from
this point on
for the next several years there is one
objective
and it's not my political future it's
better in the circumstances for the
average
america that's what it's all about and i
want to communicate to the american
people what i hope they already
understand about me
it's about them it's not about me it's
not about me
but still do you think that the climate
will be different after president trump
than it was
well we'll see i i i don't know i mean
i'm not a fortune teller but i can tell
you that
nice the calls i've gotten from
sitting republicans in powerful
positions
they know me they know i level with them
they know i never mislead
they know i tell them the truth and they
know i don't go out of my way to try to
embarrass
and in terms of the transition are there
areas where
the trump team has not been cooperative
that
have not been made public we've heard
about the issues at the the pentagon
last week
are there other areas that you think the
public should be aware of
there are other areas i'm not sure it's
relevant whether the public should be
aware of look what i'm trying to do
is pull together the political parties
that are in the congress that
know that we're facing four series
crises
and we have to address all of them none
of us will get all we want
but we can make real progress and so my
focus is on uniting
not emphasizing the divisions thank you
who's back there thank you mr
president-elect
um russia as you said is suspected
of carrying out this massive cyber hack
um you said it happened under president
donald trump's
watch but of course in january 21 it
will then of course land on your
doorstep
my question is what are the rights let's
get something to land on my doorstep his
failure will land on my doorstep
yes okay beautiful what are the
practical implications of overseeing a
government where
experts say it could take years to know
where the hackers went and years to
remove them
how can you ensure that the systems will
be safe given what experts are saying
i can't ensure but i can demand based on
the
experts both here and among our allies
what is needed to find that out it may
cost literally
billions of dollars to secure our
cyberspace
it may take a great deal to get it done
first and foremost it takes people who
are
knowledgeable and vigilant about what is
happening and how it's happening
and so i'm just going to do all that
need be done
all that need be done to determine a the
extent of the damage
b the nature of how it occurred see
what i should be doing internally in
terms of my administration to protect
against it in the future
and number four getting together with
our allies
to try to set up an international system
of what constitutes
appropriate behavior in cyberspace and
get us
all to get to the point where we hold
all hold
any other country liable for the
breaking out of those basic rules
and just be clear at the top of that did
you say you couldn't ensure that the
systems would be safe when you came into
office then
of course i can't i don't know what this
data meant
[Laughter]
shouldn't he be using the same
platitudes as everybody else
garner all the information the extent
and depth of the violations
exactly how the codes or how it were
breached
what was breached what was done is not
within my power to do that but it will
be
an overwhelming focus for my
administration
and my other question is on immigration
um i was
just reading about the fact that
officials in
your transition jake sullivan susan rice
they say you won't be immediately
rolling back trump immigration policies
and i i stress immediately
um there are some immigration advocates
who say why not roll back
the remaining mexico policy why not roll
back the
asylum restrictions what is your
timeline for rolling back some of the
specific
trump administration good question
policy excellent question we've already
started discussing these issues with the
president of mexico
and our friends in latin america
and the timeline is to do it so that we
in fact
make it better not worse the last thing
we need
is to say we're going to stop
immediately
the uh you know the access
to asylum the way it's being run now and
end up with
2 million people on our border it's a
matter of setting up the guard rails so
we can move the direction i will
accomplish what i said i would do
a much more humane policy based on
family unification
but it requires getting a lot in place
and requires getting the funding to get
in place
including just asylum judges for example
so it's a matter of it will get done
and it will get done quickly but it's
not going to be able to be done on day
one
lift every restriction that exists and
find out that
and go back to what it was 20 years ago
and all of a sudden find out
we have a crisis on our hand that
complicates what we're trying to do
would you say to immigration what would
you say to immigration advocates then
who say
maybe you're possibly dragging your feet
too it might take too long or you it
sounds like
i've never told them anything i haven't
done i'm working with them now
we're dealing with some of those very
organizations as we speak
and i will do what i said it's going to
take not day one it's going to take
probably the next six months to put that
in place
thank you so much thank you merry
christmas everybody
thank you wow
thank you thank you i promise you my
justice department
will be totally on its own making his
judgments about how they should proceed
thank you wow oh wow
could that possibly be more different
than how
so this guy at every event wants to ask
him about
articles about hunter biden from october
and
instead of throwing them out biden says
god love you and says the justice
department will investigate and i'm
going to have nothing to do with it
and they'll determine whether they need
to do something about
the tax lien on hunter biden or not
um that is that is really i mean
listen i have disagreements with some of
the things he said on
policy like i think some of the
immigration stuff could be done on day
one
while being careful that by with an
executive order
you don't end up making the situation
worse because the system's not ready for
okay i think some things could be done
on day one i think some things will take
six months maybe even eight you know
nine months
um but he's he's answering the questions
directly
and and he seems to be realistic in
terms of what
could be done on a certain timeline
and and what cannot i i think that was
very interesting
and um sort of a different feel
and by the way didn't he say merry
christmas like a dozen times wasn't
donald trump telling us that merry
christmas is over
if donald trump uh loses and joe biden
wins
i don't know that i've heard more merry
christmases during a presidential
briefing i haven't heard it from trump
i haven't heard it from marga nanny um
and i don't care one way or the other i
mean listen hanukkah's over
and christmas is next i don't celebrate
what do i care
um okay very very good excellent so an
interesting event
and uh hopefully we will we will get
more of these
thank you for joining me if you are
watching on youtube before you leave
please hit the subscribe button it's
free we are at 1.2
million subscribers can you imagine
that's insane it's
insane and if you're watching on twitch
make sure to give us a follow
um we are now more than two-thirds of
the way
to one hundred thousand one hundred
thousand over
on uh twitch thanks for joining me um
and i will be back very very soon with
everybody